in the last few days there have been
many tributes to sir david
from politicians of all parties
from his constituents and members of the
public
from friends and from family
and from faith leaders
especially the catholic church of which
he was such a devoted follower
each tribute paints its own picture
of a committed public servant
of kindness
and of a man whose decency touched
everybody that he met
taken together these tributes are a
powerful testimony
to the respect
the affection and yes the love that
david was held in
across politics
and across different communities
together they speak volumes about the
man that he was
and the loss that we grieve
so david was a dedicated parliamentarian
and his loss is felt profoundly across
this house
we are united in our grief
at this terrible time we are thinking of
david
and his family
we are thinking
once again
of our dear friend joe cox who was
killed just five short years
and i know the honourable members and
their staff will have spent the weekend
worrying about their own safety
the emotion is the same across the house
but i remember just how acutely joe's
loss was felt on these benches
so today
on behalf of the entire labour party
i want to lean across
to reach across
and to acknowledge
the pain that's felt
on the opposite benches and i do
of course our differences matter after
all that's what democracy is about
but today we're reminded that what we
have in common matters far more
i spoke to joe cox's parents on friday
afternoon
because i knew that they would be
reliving that terrible day
they said to me
they were thinking of david's family
and how their lives would be changed
forever
so today just the prime minister has
said this house holds in our hearts
david's wife julia
his children catherine david junior
sarah florence and alex
and all of those who loved him
we cannot begin to imagine
what they're going through
but our thoughts
our love
and our prayers
are with them
i also thank those who did everything
they could to save david's life and our
emergency services
who run towards danger to protect us
and i just want to take a moment
to think about
for all of us to think about
david's staff
and what they must be going through
this parliament that david loved so much
has lost one of its finest advocates
his colleagues have lost a dear friend
and the people of south end have lost
one of their own
so david was a dedicated constituency mp
when i visited south end on saturday i
was struck by the affection and the
regard that he was held in by everybody
i met
he rejected ministerial office to focus
on south end
and we remember his historic battle
to see it given city status and i'm so
pleased at the announcement the prime
minister has just made
it is a fitting tribute to sir david's
hard work it really is
fitting
because david delivered on the causes he
championed he cared about them he passed
a bill that forced action on fuel
poverty
he paved the way for better standards of
fire safety
and delivered protections for animal
welfare
and no tribute has emerged in recent
days that resonates more vividly than
that of his former parliamentary staffer
edward holmes
as he was in his first job out of
university holmes forgot to tell sir
david about an urgent call that the then
prime minister david cameron had made
he said he felt terrified
until he finally plucked up the courage
to tell david
whose response
was typical
don't worry about that edward
so relaxed was david but mr holm says he
suspects he never actually called the
prime minister back
that tells a politician who had his
priorities right
[Laughter]
one who put his people before his party
and his patch before his personal
advancement
even as a political opponent he was a
man and a politician we can all learn so
much from
i use that phrase political opponent
very deliberately
because david held his beliefs
passionately
but gently
and i believe that not only can we learn
from that
but we have a duty
to learn from that
civility matters
and it matters in politics
we must not lose sight of the fact that
david's killing was an act of terror in
our country
we can't help
today but think of joe cox
andrew pennington
and pc keith palmer
who lost his life defending all of us in
this place in 2017
and we thank god that the honourable
member for east ham is with us in the
chamber today
and that the honourable member for west
lancashire's would-be attackers were
stopped in their tracks
and i know that politicians
across the country across this house
have their own experiences of threats to
their security
today is a chance to remember david
but in the weeks and days to come we
must confront the threats and violence
that everyone faces enacting this
country's democracy
it's too early for us to comment on the
exact notifications and circumstances of
david's killing
but i do want to finish by saying this
a cowardly attack
on a public servant doing his job
is an attack on our country and on our
way of life
a way of life that prizes tolerance
democracy and respect
that accepts our differences but
cherishes our commonalities
that refuses to succumb to the poison of
extremism
no matter what perverted cause
faith or ideology these attackers
support
their intention is always the same
to sow division amongst us
and that's why our response must always
be
to show that we will never be cowed
that our bonds to one another can never
be eroded
that the hatred that took sir david's
life
will never win
our democracy is precious it's held firm
against many tests
but it's also a fragile living thing
let us use the memory of david's life
and his passions to nourish it
to recommit ourselves in standing for
the things that he stood for
the things that extremists will never
comprehend
for decency in our disagreements
for kindness in our hearts
for our great democracy
and for the hope
that through it
we can make our country
and our world
a better place